All right, here we go.
All right, everybody here we are.
And you believe it is November for the election was
yesterday. The election continues into today.
The election will continue tomorrow. The day after tomorrow,
the day after the day after tomorrow and in perpetuity,
this is our lives. We're going to live it forever now.
Um, there's so much to talk about and I just want to set the table.
Let me just set the table with you guys right now.
I am going to try to take a bit of a light tone today with all of this.
I try to give you the news in, in an easily digestible,
somewhat pleasant format, but I'm really going to double down on that today,
because first off, despite all of the insanity,
and there is a hell of a lot of insanity, I am feeling pretty good about things,
uh, perhaps more than anything else.
That's so many people actually took part in the process.
So many people care and sure.
There's a lot of people that are trying to manipulate that process right now.
And we got major problems ahead, but we also got it out of the way.
And even though it's still here, it's still sitting with us.
It's like we didn't finish the voting part at least for now.
And I think that that's kind of good and life goes on and you're not going to
believe this people. But I also do think about other things besides politics.
And I S I suppose, and I hope that you do as well.
And there are more important things out there, but this is obviously important.
Uh, everyone's sorta going bananas. We've got the charts,
the updated charts here. We're going to show them to you.
And then I was scribbling down some things right before we started,
I tried to beat myself a tic TAC toe could not do it. I could not beat myself.
I'd take tat go. Amazing. Right. So look, you know, we're,
I don't have the fake glasses today, uh, because I'm just,
I'm just going straight to you. Uh,
but we're going to talk about a lot of stuff, uh,
including a video that I'll get to in a second,
where I kind of predicted the whole, the whole thing. Uh, but before we do that,
guys, are you looking for a new protein bar that tastes like candy? Well,
I've got one for ya. I've got the brand for you. And it's in my hand right now,
built bars are super tasty and coming 18 amazing flavors.
My personal favorite is right here.
It's the cookies and cream built bars are covered in a hundred percent chocolate
and include both nut and nut free flavors and are soft and easy to chew with the
holidays just around the corner. It's easy to slip up,
which is why built bars are the perfect alternative to the pie for the health
conscious guy. I love that for a ride.
I can actually lose your maintain weight while indulging into delicious treat
built bars are low calorie, low sugar, high protein,
and high fiber go to bill barr.com and use promo code Rubin,
and you'll get 20% off your first order.
Use promo code Rubin for 20% off@billbar.com. Good for bar is built,
go or built boost. And now back to me, all right.
So I think the main takeaway matter what happens right now is the
pollsters and the mainstream media and the media elite
and the New York times and the networks that they're all wrong.
And we really should stop listening to them. As I said last night,
I don't want to put these people in jail. I don't want to put them in gulags.
I can't say I don't want to, but I don't plan on doing it. Uh, no,
I don't want to do that.
And that is not the American way to jail your political opponents,
at least for now. Um,
but some people need to be ignored.
The people who for weeks have been telling us that this thing was going to be a
blowout and the margins were bigger than last time.
And they got it all wrong last time.
But this time they weren't getting it wrong. And all of these things,
they got everything wrong again, because this is way closer.
As a matter of fact, Trump might win. I still think that's quite likely. Um,
so it's way closer.
And even the little things about minorities and things,
things that they said could never happen actually did happen.
So we're going to unpack some of the numbers and we'll get into all that.
And I'll give you the, I'll give you the latest updates,
but I want to throw to a clip of something that I did on
Monday with Glenn Beck,
I was on Glenn Beck's podcast for about an hour dissecting.
Everything that we thought we could happen would end could happen in the
election. And Glenn asked me about what could happen on election night,
if it was getting kind of close and, uh, dare I Pat myself on the back,
but let's go to the video. Well, there's so many ways to think about this,
that some of them,
I don't even want to voice because I don't want to even add energy to it.
But one of the ones that I've been thinking about is what happens if on election
night, the, the powers that be at ABC, CBS, NBC, CNN, et cetera,
let's say things are really coming in close,
but in the old days where it was like, Oh, it's, it's three points.
That actually is a lot three points towards Trump. You call it, you call it,
we've done our due diligence. You call it. Well, what if there's,
I'm not saying they're sitting in a room in a dark room with evil laughter
necessarily.
But the idea being that most of these people obviously are Democrats they're
media elite. They, they don't want to give up their power.
Why wouldn't they be on the phone going, you know what?
We're actually just not going to call Florida. It's three points on Trump,
but we're not going to really say that or something,
or we're just not going to call it. And then ABC doesn't call it. Then NBC,
doesn't call it. Then CNN doesn't call it. So I'm worried about that layer.
It's not just voter fraud in terms of the number.
It's actually the numbers translating into what the media will then communicate
with us. I'm actually more worried about that. So we, man,
it is going to be a crazy week.
The guy you're listening to right there is Dave Rubin, election prediction,
expert. Extraordinary. Yeah.
I don't have the fancy numbers and a team of data scientists and all of that
stuff that Nate silver over at five 38, uh, has,
did you see that guy on ABC last night? My God,
he looked like he got hit by a truck.
These people just keep getting everything wrong.
And some reason the pundit class keeps going back to you guys. But in essence,
what I said there was that if this thing was closed,
what would stop the networks and the machinery
from calling it? If it wasn't yeah. Going in the way that it wanted.
Now I'm not officially saying that's exactly what happened here. Okay.
But you can't say it's not sort of in the realm of what is true and
certainly in the ballpark of what is possible.
So I was on live with the daily wire guys and I was on at about
5:30 PM that w so that's Pacific time.
So about 8:30 PM Eastern.
And at that time it was still very up in the air.
There was no sense it was going either way.
It was all sort of shaking out the way it was supposed to by about seven 30
Pacific. So now this is about a 10 30 Eastern time.
Suddenly there was real momentum like Trump,
the Trump thing was starting to work. It was starting to work.
And there was a real feeling like Holy cow, this really is happening.
And then suddenly it looked like Michigan and Wisconsin and Georgia and
Pennsylvania, it looked like they were all going to go Trump.
And then by about eight 30 or so, I did my live, no,
I did my live stream here at about eight 30 Pacific.
So by about nine 30 Pacific,
suddenly the voting just seemed to have stopped in all of these places.
I didn't know that that was a thing. Suddenly people had to go home.
They couldn't count votes anymore.
This is the most important election of a generation of a lifetime ever.
Uh, people got, I take naps also. Um,
it all got very bizarre that it seemed to all happen at the exact same time.
And then I think it was at about 11:00 PM. Pacific Joe Biden came out,
gave about a four minute speech.
He stumbled and bumbled made a really weird remark at the end,
got a little confused as to who the governor of Delaware was. Uh, and then,
and then left the stage.
And then Trump came out about a half hour later and in essence said,
we won. Um, and you got to S he made a mistake. So here's what this is.
This is one of the things that were Trump and language, get a little screwy.
And then you, you throw in a dishonest media and you have a problem.
Trump in essence said, you don't go ahead and count more votes.
Now what he meant. And I, I, I would bet anything on this.
What he meant was you don't count votes. That shouldn't count.
Not that you shouldn't continue counting all of the legitimate votes,
but that's sort of like a Trump sort of, you know,
he makes these broad statements and then you have to whittle it into something.
But I could see someone watching this right now.
I can see one of you watching this right now and say, Dave,
don't give him the leash on that.
That it seems to me that that's what he was saying.
I don't think that the president of the United States was saying,
don't count legitimate votes,
but I saw a million people in the media saying the fascist has arrived.
He doesn't want us to finish the election and everything else. Um,
now the problem is that many of these States, uh, Michigan, Pennsylvania,
a couple of the others, they've got democratic governors.
Now that means that they have democratic administrations that most likely the
machinery in those States probably won't buy it and to win.
That's exactly what I was talking about with Glenn Beck on Monday that a
conspiracy isn't just, you know, it's not just the,
the evil guys in the Simpsons, laughing in the room. You know,
it's not just that,
but that it sort of moves and morphs and kind of happens in real time.
And suddenly as they,
it seems that as they kind of realize that Trump really was gonna win and the
numbers weren't looking good.
Well then suddenly they just started shutting down these States as if that's
something that we do on election night. I mean, that, that,
isn't something we do, but I do know we live in a time with, with no rules.
So I suppose anything is possible.
So I want to give you guys a quick update and then we'll talk a little bit about
the media coverage as well. Uh, as of right now,
Trump is up by about 500,000 in Pennsylvania. So that looks pretty,
pretty solid. Apparently they have to vote.
They have to do some counting in the Philadelphia area that could go more
blue. You know, big cities tend to go more blue,
but the chances that they make up 500, probably not great. That's what 66% in,
in Michigan Biden is up 50, which is pretty negligible at 96% in.
So that clearly could go either way, but by, in technically, as in the lead,
Biden's up 20,000 in Wisconsin, which has absolutely nothing.
And I'm pretty sure that the Trump administration has already said,
they're going to demand a recount there that's with 95% in,
and then the other two big ones at the moment, uh,
Trump is up by 80,000 votes in Georgia,
not a tremendous amount, uh, but that's with 95% in,
and Trump is up 80,000 votes as well, with 94% in,
in North Carolina. So that's kind of where we stand at the moment. And if,
if the recounts are happening right now and there are notion Nanigans,
then hopefully we will have some answers. I mean, nobody wants this thing. Well,
let me not say nobody. Most people don't want this thing to last pass today.
Right? Um, I think most people wanted it to wrap up last night. And,
and let me just be very clear on this.
If the numbers had come back and it was clear that Joe Biden had one, well,
you guys know I wanted Trump to win and I still want Trump to win. Right.
I think that is the, I think he is the leader for this time,
this bizarre time we lead in here, uh, we live in,
he is the guy that can lead us most effectively. Uh,
if you care about the things that I care about. So I'm,
I'm putting my cards on the table here, right? I'm not,
I'm not hiding behind anything like everyone on network news does it as if they
have no opinions about any of these things. Meanwhile, you know,
I'm watching ABC news last night and it's anchored by telling you this George
Stephanopoulos, former Clinton staffer. And who's he sitting next to,
but Rahm Emanuel, former Clinton staffer,
and then they've got all Democrats around them. And then Chris,
Christie's there. Now he's a big guy.
So maybe he counts as a couple of Republicans, but it's like, in essence, you,
you guy, he liked that one. Michael liked that one. Um, so, okay,
so I'm putting my cards on the table. So I'm telling you, I,
I do want Trump to win, but if the numbers came back and it was an obvious win,
then I would have absolutely accepted this, accepted that last night.
And then I would have had to do an autopsy on what I talk about here
and maybe did I see something wrong or whatever, but in essence,
the things that I've been talking about here, this election,
because of the really high numbers for Trump, um, in essence,
this is, this is so when, for the future of the Republican party,
I think either way, because they started to get more diverse,
which we'll get into in a minute. And, and the numbers really did go up. So,
so that is good. But here's the question now, it's what I said to Glenn.
How do we trust the machine right now? Like you watching this right now,
do you trust the machine? Do you trust that Philadelphia? Yeah.
Which is in Pennsylvania,
obviously that those people there are democratic run Philadelphia in a
democratic run state by a attorney general with an attorney general,
this Shapiro guy, not, not Ben Shapiro, different Shapiro.
That's a good Shapiro. This is the bad Shapiro who literally said days ago.
And we talked about it the other day, uh,
that that Biden will win Pennsylvania. That's what he said before election day.
That's what the attorney general of Pennsylvania said.
So do you trust the machinery? Meaning the, the machinery,
the political machinery of Pennsylvania, which happens to be democratic,
do you trust them to, to actually count the votes? Honestly,
if they feel like they can actually flip the election,
which they potentially have the power to do. And then do you,
at the secondary level, do you trust what I was talking about with Glenn?
You trust the media elites, who all want this guy out?
Do you trust them to do the right thing? As I said before,
it's not conspiracy to say, I don't think these people are fully trustworthy.
I don't think that's it conspiracy theory. Right. So if you're,
if you're out there right now and you're confused and you're not totally sure
who to trust, and you think the system's a little whacked, your, your,
that means you're, you're kind of thinking right now, like everybody else,
that's just like,
get me the numbers and I want the numbers and the numbers better be what I want
them to be. And that's how it's going to be. And it's like, come on, man. Like,
that's not what we're doing here. You see what? I just, I just did a Biden ride.
Come on, man. That was my Biden impression right there. Um,
so I think that that sort of trust level is,
is a huge problem that we've got right now. And I don't know how we get past it.
So my hope here's my hope right now. My hope is that out of the,
the States that I just read off to you, Michigan, Pennsylvania, Wisconsin,
Georgia, and North Carolina,
if we can get results that are tangible results,
uh, from those States, then we can probably declare a winner today.
It doesn't sound like it's going to happen. I mean,
even you could even see on ABC, especially last night,
the entire time they were teasing, Oh, we're going to need a week for this.
We're going to need a week for this. And the thing is, you guys know this,
remember two weeks to flatten the curve. That's what the,
the establishment told us back in March about COVID now we're eight months
later, right? So when they tell you, Oh, we need a week to figure this out.
Well, before you know, it it's six months before you know it,
we're fighting this thing out in Supreme court,
right before the new president or the returning president is supposed to be
sworn in on January 20th. So we got a, we got a big set of problems,
but in essence,
I think what Trump did last night was he basically drew a line in the sand.
He said, first off, I'm going to, I'm going to fight. He said,
we're winning in these key States. We've got these numbers here.
We think we're going to win them. And by the way, that's what Biden said too.
So they're both in essence saying the same thing. We're losing here,
we're wearing it here, but we think we're going to win.
We think we're gonna win. Okay. That's fine. That's just politics. But,
but what, in essence, Trump said, he did say the F-word right? He said,
he said the fraud word. So that's number one. Um,
but he also basically drew a line in the sand and made it clear that if
they feel that there are shenanigans and that's a legitimate
fear that is not calling the election into question, that is a legitimate fear.
Uh, well then in that case that then they'll go to the courts. Now,
do we want this thing going to the courts? If it, I mean,
if this thing goes to the courts,
that means it's worked its way through the system,
the States have made decisions.
We're not totally sure if those decisions were right.
And then we got to get this thing all the way to the Supreme court,
knowing that Trump put in three of these people,
knowing how contentious that is. I mean,
maybe it feels like it's all just supposed to go that way because,
because the energy of the universe or something is just,
is just dragging us that way. But, but I hope that is not what happens.
I hope that maybe there are some elected officials in these
States who care about getting it right more than getting their
guy in. And you know,
you can't be bringing in votes that weren't postmarked by election day and you
can't be doing all of this random stuff. You know, there was this,
there was this, uh,
image going around Twitter this morning of apparently a hundred thousand
extra votes that magically appeared in Michigan for Biden overnight.
So meaning Biden's number went up by a hundred thousand from the time they
stopped counting until the morning, but Trump's, didn't move now.
That's mathematically impossible. It is literally impossible.
And I'm not using the word, literally figuratively. I'm using it,
literally that Joe Biden or Trump. But in this case,
Biden could get a hundred thousand votes with the competitor getting zero votes.
Now they're saying that somebody actually made a mistake and they forgot to put
a one in there. And it's closer to like 15,000 votes for Biden, not,
not a hundred thousand,
but like this sort of stuff is what we're just going to keep hearing more of.
And the unfortunate part is it makes people worry. It makes people go, man,
is the system strong enough to withstand this stuff? Is it,
is it trustworthy enough? I don't know exactly what the answer is.
I don't think anyone knows exactly what the answer is.
And I certainly don't think that anyone watching mainstream media is going to
get anything saying, I mean, whatever you do,
I hope you give me a couple of minutes of your day, right?
Like that that's wonderful. And this thing's really growing.
And I guess I've carved out a nice little space in that. Um,
but you should not be sitting at home. You know,
we're all sitting at home because of these stupid lockdowns.
You should not have CNN on all day.
And I don't even mean that just to make fun of CNN,
it's easy to make fun of CNN.
You shouldn't have any of these channels on all day waiting every minute for the
breaking news of th this, uh, state operatives said that,
that through when he forgot to carry the one and this guy is going there and
they postmark this, like it will make you crazy. So try not to do it.
I don't know if you come here for life advice, but try not to do it.
I don't even have cable anymore, so we don't keep those channels on. Um, but,
but if you want to be engaged in this, it's like, yeah,
you can check in every couple of hours, flip through Twitter,
see what's on your Facebook feed and the rest of it so that you're aware of
what's happening, but, but don't be sucked in at that level.
The idea that we're all trapped at home now,
and then we're watching all of this stuff more and it's designed to make us all
crazy and make us hyper-partisan and everything else. It's, it's,
it's kinda dangerous. Um, all right. So let's, let's step away though,
from like the specifics of what happened,
cause it's going to keep unfolding and I promise you, I will,
I will do my best to communicate whatever the truth is to you.
Whether I like it or not. Uh, I want to move on to, uh,
to two stories here that have to do with race,
because it turns out that in a lot of the exit polls,
and I'm not a huge fan of exit polls,
the idea that someone walks out after voting,
and there's an exit pollster there and they ask them, you know, what,
who they voted for and what are the issues they care about, whatever. It's like,
if someone approached me as I walked out of the booth the other day,
I would've been like, go after yourself. Like, I don't need to talk to you.
You know what I mean? Like, it's my business, that's it. And I'm a,
I'm a public person and disregard. Um, so I don't like the idea of it.
And we know that people mess with, with pollsters,
Scott Adams has talked a lot about this, how, especially Trump people, you know,
you're,
you're kind of closeted about your Trump's support depending on where you live.
You're not going to just walk out of the thing and then just like tell a random
person what you think about everything. Um, but the,
but from the exit polls, it does seem, uh,
that there was a real minority shift.
And now we're seeing this in actual voting numbers that are coming out now that
there was a real shift in, in the minority vote. Uh,
but that is very unfortunate for the people that trade and race all day long.
And in essence, this is really what the, the left the establishment does.
It's pretty much all they've got. So joy Reed, who is a host on MSNBC,
who is not a good person, I'm sorry, she's just not,
she has written a lot of anti gay stuff from years ago that apparently was
hacked into her computer.
And then everyone just dropped it because she's a lefty.
But if she was on the right, she would've been canceled. Um, she's,
she's sort of the worst kind of partisan thing and trades and just making it
seem like everyone is racist.
We'll watch this clip from joy Reed on MSNBC last night.
But if somehow they managed to stumble into the Supreme court.
Did any of you guys,
uncle Clarence and Amy Coney Barrett and those guys to actually follow the
letter of the law? No. I mean, it is a completely politicized Supreme court.
You want to know what modern racism is, guys,
that there are no people out there that don't think black people
should be allowed to use the same water fountains.
Everyone believes that virtually everyone in the United States wants a quality.
It doesn't care what your skin color is and doesn't care what your gender is.
And in most cases doesn't even care what your sexuality is. Okay.
That is a fact that doesn't mean that there aren't fringe weirdos,
that don't think those things, but they have no power.
That is a host of a 24 hour cable news network
using a slur. Okay. Using a slur, uncle Clarence,
you see what she's getting at there, right? It started,
it's a name that starts with a T that's three letters that if I say,
if I say the phrase, uncle blank, if I say it,
we know that this video automatically gets the monetized audit automatically.
The way the system works. They'll find me saying it. They will, de-magnetize it.
I don't even care about the money,
but what that will then do is hurt it in the algorithm.
And then less people will see it. She just used a racial slur. Imagine,
imagine if a conservative did what she just did,
media matters.
And all of these lefty loonies would be calling for whoever's head. It is,
but somehow the anti-racists,
the anti-racists of the left are actually allowed to be the most racist towards
black people. So joy Reed, if you are watching this,
you are a racist, you're a genuine racist.
You are a modern racist and good luck with that.
And I have no doubt that you'll continue at MSNBC, but of course,
joy Reed is not the only modern racist, uh, Jamil Hill, who you may remember.
She was, uh, at ESPN and then went crazy, woke on him. Well,
she tweeted this.
If Trump wins reelection, it's on white people.
No one else, white people, no one else.
Well now first off you're male, um, white people are entitled to their opinions.
White people are allowed to vote for whoever their conscience dictates,
just like black people and Asian people and all other people everyone's
allowed to vote for who they think. Now, the funny thing of course,
of what she said here,
and she's one of the prime purveyors of just trading and race all day long,
she's become super successful in the most patriarchal racist society
ever.
I saw her once in the Inn at lax airport and she was walking with Michael
Jordan, not Michael Jordan, Chicago bulls, Michael Jordan, the actor, Michael B,
Jordan who played creed. Right. And they were walking together and he's,
you know, pimped out in his fancy outfit.
And she's in some crazy outfit with these furry shoes.
And like the furry shoes were clearly a lot of dos.
So she's doing okay in this deeply racist state. I don't have furry shoes.
I don't want furry shoes, but I wouldn't even know where to get burry shoes.
The point is, uh, she's doing okay here,
but they trade in racism that no longer exists,
but don't even take my word for it.
Let's look at some of the numbers because they're actually pretty fascinating.
And you're not going to believe this guys let's pull up the numbers,
Donald Trump, you know, Mr. Mr. Hitler, Nazi white supremacist, Donald Trump,
he just got the highest share of the nonwhite vote for the
Republicans since 1960.
So if you just quickly run through these numbers in 1960,
they got 32% of non-white voters,
and then it's been pretty messy and depressing since then. Uh,
it bottomed out four years later, it went from 32% to 6%. I mean, that's,
that's actually incredible. And then it was sort of 12, 13, 15, 10, 13, 18,
a little higher 11, 12, nine, 17, 10, 11,
and then in 2016. Okay. And this is Trump's first time around.
It actually went up a bit, right. So we went up 10 points, okay. In 2016,
and then it went up another, at least it's preliminary at the moment,
but it went up another five points.
So that means in the two elections that Donald Trump has taken place in 2016
and 2020,
that means that non-white vote for the Republicans has
actually gone up 15%. That is pretty amazing.
And it makes you think that no, these people,
aren't all uncle whatever.
And that the election of Donald Trump the first time and potentially the second
time, isn't just on white people.
But if you want to just live in your depressed reality,
then I suppose you can go ahead and do it. Um, okay guys,
so I'm going to jump for now. Uh, there's obviously a lot going on.
I got a couple of other podcasts that I'm doing,
and it's obviously going to be a bit of a haywire week.
We're going to be going five days a week here for awhile. You know,
originally when I started doing this direct message thing,
we said three days a week, Tuesday through Thursday. Uh,
but there's obviously so much going on and the reaction's been so fantastic and
I'm actually loved doing this. And I think we're,
we're doing something important throughout the chaos that, uh,
we're going to do it five days a week. And if things really break today, I'll,
I'll come back and we'll do another live stream and all that as always,
if you want to communicate with me directly, join us@rubinreport.com,
which by the way,
I put out a link to Rubin report.com today on Twitter and Twitter,
it was warning people that, uh, that it could be a fraudulent website, uh,
and that it may be giving fake news something to that effect. I, I tweeted the,
the screenshot of that. Um, so you know, our big tech overlords,
they're always up to something anyway, uh, stay calm. We're,
we're going to get through this thing one way or another. And, and I, I still,
I'm, I'm feeling confident. I'm feeling good about everything. And even if,
even if it doesn't go the way I want it to go, if,
if we get through this in an honest, sensible way,
and that's a big gift and everything, everything will be okay. And if not,
let's build a bunker or let's build a rocket and let's get the hell out of here.
So we've got options. Okay. Have a good day, everybody.